。
同学们好啊，上课了。
牛年第一课。
牛年开箱。
拍的有点晚了是吧？都出正月了。
所以弄得我也有点不好意思。我今天上课前啊琢磨了半天。
怎么跟同学们解释一下，为什么这么晚开课？
没找到什么好的理由啊。
就是忙。
耽误了。
本来说好的说咱们牛年呀。
呃，要花更多的时间和精力。
讲我们的这个编剧课。
要讲。
更。
实用的内容更进阶的内容。
这个承诺没有变啊。
没有变，咱们从今天开始就就就就实现它，好吧。
那么为什么说在今年想把这个课。
更提一个档次呢。
是因为啊。
现在是3月，咱们去年也是3月录的课是吧？
一年了一年了，咱们通过这一年的时间啊。
积累的这些课程，积累的这些。
我们说是个建制嘛。
第一幕见制嘛。
说建制的这个学习环境其实是很不容易的一个事情。
我们应该珍惜，为啥呢？因为在现在的这个社会啊。
大家应该明显的感受到现在的社会啊。
他实际上是一个。
信息碎片化的时代。
也就是说你接受到的资讯。
接受到的知识。
很多。
很杂。
很快。
这没有什么不好。
这没有什么不好，这是社会的进步。
碎片化。
但是呢。
他不利于学习。
不利于深度学习。
他更利于跨界和。
综合性的认知，它不利于专门的专业的深度的学习。
所以你想要深度学习呢，现在环境越来越少。
也就是说，对于深度学习，环境变恶劣。
我之前说过，学习这是逆水行舟啊，就是这个意思。因为大部分人在随波逐流，每天刷抖音啊哈一天可以刷几百条。
那就是随波逐流。
而你呢在沉下心学一门学问，你就是逆水行舟。
当然很难嘛。
所以说咱们创造的这个学习环境，聚拢了这些同学。
形成了一定的学习习惯。
非常难能可贵的一个事儿。
我们要珍惜好不好？
学习不是件容易的事情。
我们既然有这个机会凑在一起了。
我们就把它好好学学出点成果。
对不对？
我们不说说不说什么知识改变命运吧，那至少改变自我嘛，提升一下好不好？这就是咱们课程今年为什么要好好讲的一个原因。因为学习啊真的不容易。
另外在春节的时候啊，我也跟大家承诺过。
今年会帮大家创造更多的就业机会。
这礼拜。
就有。
两场。
招聘会。
就是影视公司跟咱们编剧课官方合作的招聘会。
同学们留意一下，好吧，留意一下班委会的通知。另外咱们今年呢也在计划中的。
咱们编剧课。
会成立官方的。
呃。
剧本公司或者叫编剧公司吧。
把咱们。
嗯，同学中。
优秀的。
阿标的这些创作者。
聚拢在一起。
直接为。
那些影视企业制作单位、投资公司提供剧本。好吧，咱们今年呢尽量把这个事儿也给他办成。
然后昨天还在跟班委会讨论这个事情的时候呢，提到。
说咱们这个你看啊咱们。
做招聘会其实也事儿也挺多的，忙忙叨叨的。
组织安排考试、面试。
鄙视。
那题全都是我出我批，然后呢，班委会的同学去去组织。
然后呢，就是考虑说。
哎，为什么我们这个事儿对企业，对咱们的同学，对双方都是免费的。
难以置信是吧？
对，双方都是免费的。
在这里我也跟大家解释一下。
为什么对双方都是免？
因为学习本来就不容易。
生活其实更不。
同学们，我在课上其实经常鼓励大家，我经常说一些什么样的话啊？我经常跟大家说努力。
就会有成绩，对吧？
你只要肯学就一定能学会。
勤奋永远不会被埋没的对吧？
我经常说这种类型的话。
鼓励大家。
很正能量。
搞得好像我不食人间烟火一样。其实不是的啊同学。
我也知道生活不容易。
我也知道。
其实。
有时候机会和机遇。
是会起到决定性的作用。
同学们，我自己。
本身就来自一个小县城。
我是一个来自小县城的农村孩子。
家里条件很差的。
所以我当然能体会到。
机会的。
同学们，我。
我在上海和北京都飘过。
在中国最大的两个城市当过沪漂和北漂。
我你以为我没有感受过。
世态炎凉，没有感受过。
举目无亲，走投无路的那种感觉吗？
我当然知道。
所以。
我很能体会到。
机会的不容易。
所以尽力的给大家。
创造点机会。
因为生活不容易。
我的生活比你们的生活可能相对容易。
那么我就。
呃，多付出点，多创造点，好不好？
我就是通过学习改变命运的。
我是通过高考。
走出来。
高考肯定也不是公平的啊，我可以负责任的跟大家说，但是高考也是一个改变命运的非常好的机会。因为。
他是可以通过努力。
就能。
实现的。
那咱们现在做做的这个事儿。
学习编剧技巧也是通过努力可以实现的呀。
所以同学们一定要努力学。
至于机会呢。
当然也很重要，机会和机遇呢也很重要。我呢尽量吧，我只能说尽我的能力。
给大家。
多创造一点。
那种心灵鸡汤的书上书啊。
说人的一生。
有三次改变命运的机会是吧，大部分人一一错过了。
只要能抓住一次就怎样呢。
我平常其实挺反对大家。
海心灵鸡汤的。
但是这句话我觉得其实有道理。
我其实回顾我。
快40年的人生。
我也觉得人生啊确实有几个关键的节点可以改变你。
一定要努力。
话又说多了。
不聊这些了，好吧。
总之就是跟大家说。
咱们好好上课，好好学，好好生活，加油好不好？就这意思，赶紧上课啊。
这节课讲啥呢？
这节课呢。
我们就要这个这个这个。
兑现我们。
春节的时候说的，我们要讲点。
更实用更进阶的知识。
今天这节课给大家讲。
叙事视角的问题。
趋事视角。
我们说。
电影是有叙事视角。
就是你一个故事呈现给观众的时候。
是谁在讲？
是你在讲吧，理论上啊是创作者在讲。
那你站在什么位置讲的呢？
你站在那个位置。
就决定了。
你这个故事的视角。
对不对？
所以说电影里面啊。
或明或暗。
是有一个讲述者的。
或者说说是这个整个故事的一个组织者。
这个问题啊。
在过往的教材里面。
是不涉及的。
也就是说，在近些年啊。
才新兴起来的一门学科。
他也是有庞杂的体系的啊，他出现了之后，大家发现我操这个事情确实重要啊。
就开始研究出体系了。
甚至有些过度研究。
过度研究，但是呢也能证明这个玩意儿啊它确实挺重要的。
特别对于现代的叙事，对于当下的电影的发展。
电影的故事的讲述。
确实很重要。
确实值得讲一讲。所以今天咱就讲一讲这个。
在影视作品中。
这个视角问题。
当然了，一节课不可能完全都探讨明白。
我们就这节课算是一个概述吧。好吧，我希望你通过这节课以后在这方面。
心里做到心里有数。
首先我们说那这个视角。
不太好理解，对吧？我们先从好理解的下手。
同学们都喜欢看小说是吧？
小说。
里面的视角是比较明确的。
我们都知道写小说有两种视角可以选。
一种叫。
叫第三人称。
是吧一种叫。
第一人称。
就有这两种视角的小说。
第三人称啥叫第三人称？
他呀。
或者说直呼姓名嘛。
那个谁谁谁怎么样怎么样，哎，咱们就说。
胡八一怎样怎样，王胖子怎样怎样。
希尔里昂怎样怎样对吧？鬼吹灯。
然后第一视角呢，那就是我。
同样是鬼吹灯，鬼吹灯其实就是第一式第一人称写的嘛。
他用那个胡八一的视角嘛来。
我今天经历了什么事儿？然后我看到王胖子。
这个死胖子这样怎样这样，哎呦，十里阳款款走来，真他妈好看。
第一人称视角。
这就是小说。
经常用的。
两种视角。
它有什么区别呢？
第三人称。
他实际上。
是一个讲述视角，你发没发现？就我给你讲个故事啊。
从前有个什么样的山，山上有个什么样的和尚？
山下又有一个什么样的。
对吧尼姑你知辈说山下为什么有尼姑？反正就是给你讲讲述一个故事。
方方面面吧。
方方面面，而且呢。
其实是相对传统的一种讲法。
你有没有发现？
就是说过去的小说啊。
至少中国古代所有的小说都是第三人车。
而第一人称啊相对比较新。
比较现代。
的一种手法，他就不是讲述了。
他是。
展示。
来吧，展示是吧？
因为。
他直接是通过故事中的一个人物。
带着你去经历，那他可不就是展示嘛？就我看到啥，我就告诉你啊，我听到啥我也告诉你。
我感受的啥，我也告诉你，我经历啥，我告诉你，你跟着他一块就完事儿了。
这就是来吧，展示。
这种手法呢比较现代。
这种手法呢比较传统。
这就是小说的。
两种叙事视角。
我们说电影的叙事视角啊。
比小说是要复杂的。
但是呢。
也没有跳出。
这个框框。
在电影的叙事视角里面，我们先说。
基本理论好吧，在电影的叙事视角里面。
也有第三人称视角。
也就是说。
方方面面给你讲述的这种视角。
我们叫。
全职视角。
全是视角。
然后。
这种。
给你直接来吧展示的这种视角呢，我们叫限制视角。
限制视角。
前肢视角也叫。
无视角。
还有个更通俗的词儿。
上帝视角。
这个更好理解对不对？这个更好理解吧，上帝视角呀，你是上帝呀，讲述者是上帝，哎呀哎呀低头看着芸芸众生哎。
你看啊这有个山，山还有一个和尚，哎，这和尚你看啊表面上跟师傅在那。
这个这个敲木语念经。
一本正经呢，实际上惦记着山下的小尼姑。然后呢，这个这个呃花开两朵，咱们各表一枝，这边咱们按下不表，我们看看小尼姑在干什么。小尼姑呢，虽然跟山上的和尚有点什么事儿，但是呢其实跟村里的谁谁唉就。
这你看这就是上帝视角，你啥都知道。
你啥都知道。
所以你可不就是讲述嘛，所以这种全真视角对应的其实是小说中的所谓的第三人称。
也就是上帝视角。
这是电影叙事的第一种视角。然后电影叙事的限制视角。
也就是。
直接对应第一人称吗？其实并不是它有两种。
限制视角呢分两种，一种对应第一人称，我们叫他。
内视角。
类似角也就是说叙事者叙事视角。我们说电影我们其实找的是叙事者嘛，对吧？叙事者的位置嘛，其实就是你的位置，咱们大家都是编剧，咱们就不见外了啊，咱们就不叫叙事者了，咱们就叫你。
就你站在哪？
全真视角，你就是站在。
上地位的。
你开天眼啊，我们讲你开天眼的吗？
那么。
你选择把哪些告诉观众，哪些不告诉观众，你选择随意的揉搓信息，对吧？
那么其实你的是你的。
就是你。
大于。
人物。
对不对？你比下面芸芸众生知道的都多。
你大于人物。
然后呢，限制视角的所谓的内视角，其实也就是对应的第一人称叙事。
在这种情况下。
叙事者，也就是你。
等于这。
等于0。
去事者等于人。
理解了。
就是叙事者呀。
你附着在某个人物身上。
你跟着胡八一一块经历这些事儿。
你看到啥就是啥，你听到啥就是啥。
痛苦着你的痛苦，悲伤着你的悲伤啊，对吧？有首歌不是这么唱的吗？
所以说内视角那显然就是在故这个故事内嘛。
内视角也叫内聚焦啊，在这个故事内附着在某个人物上。
附着在某个人物上。
一般来说是主角。
我们在讲人物的时候讲过这个问题啊。
说人物和观众的关系，说人物拉小车啊，拉着。
咱们的观众走。
那么观众的视角岂不是就是跟你这个人物是相等的吗？你们俩一块听一块儿看。
所以说这就是内视角，然后在电影叙事中。
他们在理论上又提炼出了第三种视角。
脚外视角。
在外视角。
那这个是你叙事者大于人物，这个是叙事者等于人物。很显然，那这个外触角就是叙事者小于人物。
趋事者小于任物。
这个怎么去理解呢？
我们这么去理解。
在内视角里面。
叙事者等于人物。也就是说叙事者是拟人。
他是有灵魂，有思维，有温度的。
最起码。
那么所谓的外视角，其实就是叙事者不是人。
就是这个视角不是个人呐。
他只是客观的存在在这个事件当中。
他冷眼看世界。
他不投入。
那他所知道的。
他的视角小于人物是什么意思？他知道的比人物少。
他有时候没太看明白是怎么回事，他就看闹闹哄哄的这群人都在干什么，表象上都在干什么，我不去探究你们的内心，因为我也没有能力探究你的内心，因为我不是人。
咱们因为是影视嘛。
你可以理解为我就是个摄像机。比如说。
我是个冷酷的摄像机，我只管记录。
对吧。
你们到底是怎么回事呢？
我不去。
干涉因为我也没有能力干涉，我不去猜测。
我也不去假定。
所以说外视角叙事者是小于任务的。
这就是电影叙事视角的。
三个基本分类不是很好理解，对吧？
光说定义啊，光说知识啊很干涩。
咱们在以前的课程中啊，一般尽量避免直接说知识。
我们来。
探究一下他们的区别，他们的优劣。
他们的特点。
来。
全职视角。
有什么优点？
我们来看一下。
很显然啊。
全职视角。
因为你站在上帝的角度。
首先你是比较客观。
你不偏不倚啊。
你对不你没有带入主角或者代入某一个角色，你还是比较客观的。
另外呢，你掌握的资讯比较全面。
你动心一切呀。
这边我们的主角还在家睡觉呢。
对手那个大坏蛋已经提着刀在路上。
你看见。
是吧你洞悉一切。
所以呢你的叙事比较全面。
比较客观。
然后呢比较自由。
比较自由的叙事呀。
你很好发挥，你想写哪写哪。
想描写谁描写谁。
而且还可以多线索虚事。
多线索多线趋势。
这不就是。
上帝视角的优点吧。
这就是上帝视角的优点。同样啊，我们说你看在小说里面，我们说第三人称是比较传统的。
第一人称是比较现代的，在电影里面也是这样。
全职视角，也就是所谓的上帝视角是比较传统的。
你看到过的。
大部分的骗子。
大部分的电影。
大部分的影视。
电影电视剧。
都是全职视角。
大部分。
举例子的话，当然也很好举啊，太多了。
不是枚举。
我们就说春节档吧，唐探这种。
对吧这边在干什么，那边在干什么，警察在干什么？
宝强和那个谁在干什么？
日是上帝视角。
或者这么说吧，举例子咱不用举，你看看你写的肯定是上帝视角，你自己看一看，你自己看一看你写的，你看一看就知道啥叫上帝视角了。你就是你写的就是你写的就是你放心吧，没跑。
对吧。
好吧。
这就是上帝视角的特点。
我们说来内视角有什么特点？
我们说上级视角那些优点。
他肯定就不具备了。
他肯定就不具备吧，他有自己的优点。
内视角啊，你等于人物，那你肯定就不客观了。
你不客观的话，你主观呀你主观主观又不是贬义词呀，主观有什么优点？
感情浓烈呀。
共情强呀。
你跟主角是命运共同体呀。
我们说你悲伤，他的悲伤忧伤，他的忧伤嘛。
感情浓烈。
而且呢。
我们说全职视角呃这个这个这个多线叙事很全面。那你。
内视角的时候，你摒去全面了，人让你强烈呀，你单一，但是强烈呀。
流畅呀。
你不用管其他人发生什么，我就走我自己这一条线，我剧情流畅。
紧张。
对不对？
强烈我们之前比喻过。
说是拉着小车。
拉着小车，观众坐在后面，那拉小车经历这个故事，那观众岂不是就是身临其境啊？
投入呀。
让观众的情绪更强烈，因为他身临其境了，代入感强。
参与感强。
這就是。
内视角的优势。
优势，而且内视角啊。
更容易探究人性。
因为你跟着主角走，我们说这主角可不是。
一路上都是在做正确的决定吧。
我们在课上说过，主角在。
旅程中其实要做两次错误决定的，记不记得？
那么他在跟着你一起做这些决定的时候，是不是又探究了人性了？
是不是就拷问了灵魂了呢？
这就是内时交的。
或者说是优势。
我们说这些特点优势就是对应你怎么去选择啊。
我们讲这节课也是有有有用的啊，不是说只是去了解一下。
视角分类，然后你又永远就写你自己。
呃，的那一套，不是的啊，你得学会运用啊。我们说呢全职视角有全职视角的特点，那他适用的片子。
是哪一种？
那全职视角来开天眼，那是适合呢适合事件比较复杂。
人物比较多。
对不对？你要综合的。
空盘看全局，否则看不明白。那你这种片子岂不是就是。
需要。
开天眼嘛。
内视角呢，你你你你这个单一大男主或者单一大女主。
他的个人的命运。
是这个故事的这个这个这个主线，对吧？它的成长弧线很大。
然后呢，他的个性色彩很浓。
他他他这个这个这个这个。
他很有感染力，很有感召力。
那你就是应该考虑。
用内视角。
我们说那这两种。
上立视角和内视角都是非常常用。
其实都挺常用。
内饰要的片子，那呃咱们还以春节档为例啊，老片子咱就不说了，老片子阿凡达。
咱们课上讲过了阿凡达，我还说过呢，他开场就那个那个那个那个那个主角叫杰克嘛，就在那，我是一个特种兵。
我呢心里是咋想的，咱就只要一说自己心里是咋想的，你就知道他是就是内视角了。
对不对？
一说自己心里是咋想的？
这种片子就是内饰角。
就内心的声音啊。
一想起，那这种片子就是那视角阿凡达，咱们这个这个这个春节档还说春节档的例子。
李焕英。
那不就是内视角吗？
对吧。
穿越的基本都是内视角。
你你要经历的这些事。
观众跟着你一块经历嘛，因为穿越是一个很奇怪的事情嘛。
这就是内视角。我们说比较不常用的是外视角。
我们说外视角听着就有点怪。
是吧它非人类。
他的信息量呢还小于人物，他知道的少。
那这个这个讲故事还有什么意思啊？
你这个讲述者啥也不知道。
你不开天眼也就罢了。
你连人物都不如。
你都不知道这个人在想什么。
那你这个讲故事的人。
会不会也太。
你还给我们讲什么，对吧？我们我们为什么要听你这故事呢？
其实也是有自己的优势的。
首先我们说上帝视角相对客观，因为他不代入代入人物。
但其实最客观的是外视角。
因为他都没有生命，你上帝好歹也是。
对吧也是个生命嘛。
你好歹也有自己的喜好，自己的观点嘛。
你有自己的取舍。
但是外视角是没有的。
外视角更冷静，更客观，更冷眼，旁观一切。
他不参与。
任何人的内心。
也不参与是非对错的判断。
不参与取舍。
所以他最客观最冷静。
当然了，因为他小于人物，你还可以说他还有个什么优势，他有留白，这就是没有优势的优势啊，他有留白，他有想象空间，他刻意了刻意的制造了观众对角色的想象。
因为我们也不知道他咋想的，反正这些事情就是在这么发生着。
这种片子啊。
也有。
比如说。
大家回去看一下啊。
有个美剧叫副总统。
副总统大家可以去看一下。
还有一个叫摩登家庭，摩登家庭，你去看标准的外视角不参与任何。
不参与任何这个。
角色不参与任何任务。那这种叙事方式。
咱们在实战中是怎么去运用呢？
你可以这么理解，外视角呢是无视角和内视角的。
进一步极端。
或者叫进一步妥协。
你发生的这个故事。
你追求它的真实性。
追求它的客观性。
也没有。
兴趣去解读。
只是让观众去欣赏。
藤的欣赏。
在这种情况下是可以用无视角的。
大家回去看一下那个副总统和摩登加。
就知道我们在说什么。
这就是三种视角。
分别的特点。
和分别的适用场景。
参考片的话。
上帝视角最多，大家随便去看。
内视角的。
泰他阿凡达。
太大分了。
李焕英啊。
都是这种。
外视角的呢。
其实大部分的战争片都是外视交同学们。
为什么？我们刚才说了啊，外视角这个视角有什么特点？
客观。
不掺和。
不参与。
残酷。
冷酷吗？
那什么东西符合这几个特点？
站着。
战争片就是这样。
战争片里面我不需要开天眼。这场战争，比如说二战的片子，你都知道怎么回事，所有人都知道。
谁跟谁打的没有什么悬念。
人物呢所有的人物都是都变成了战争的机器，变成杀戮的机器。我也我也无意走进他们任何人的内心。
所以说你看外视角是不是就是无视角和内视角的进一步妥协？
战争片。
很多都是外视角。
比如说。
我能想到的拯救大命主耶。
拯牛拉边。
就很冷酷。
这一个外视角。
同样是。
这个。
汤姆汉克斯的。
今年的汇猎拳哈。
大家去看一下。
什么叫外视角？
什么叫外市角。
所以说战争片。
这种比较残酷的。
计时风格的。
故事。
你是可以考虑外视角。
这里讲到了拯救大兵瑞安。
为了防止大家抬杠，我给大家讲一下拯救大兵瑞恩为什么是外世件，拯救大兵瑞恩啊。
起头其实是瑞恩的回忆。
对吧被拯救的是马特达蒙嘛。
ran这个角色。
他。
去扫墓。
去追忆这些为了救他而牺牲的战友。
然后再引出了当时的故事。
这其实是个假回忆。
其实是个假回忆。
因为马特达蒙作为被拯救者，是在故事的终点。我们说拯救大兵瑞恩这种故事一听，任务线非常明确，我们再回趁这个机会回忆一下以前的知识啊，拯救大兵瑞恩。
小蝌蚪找妈妈是一个句式，对不对？你去找瑞恩呀，那么什么时候找到瑞恩？
终点。
故事的终点找到瑞恩。
所以那在找到他之前，这些事情是。
运人怎么知道？
所以岳言是不知道。
女人是不知道。
所以在很多故事里面。
首先我们定性拯救大明营瑞安是个外视角的片子，因为它是个冷酷的战争。
但是。
因为泰它毕竟是个商业大片。
太过冷酷呢。
观众看起来是很累的。
所以他套用了一个。
瑞恩的回忆。
作为前面的一个小帽子。
来修饰了一下。
外视角。
形成一定程度的。
内视角。
不太好理解对吧？借由这个我们就讲一下关于视角的另外一种观点。
我们先把拯救大明瑞渊放下。
我们来看一下这三种视角。
无视角内视角外视角。
这是一种说法。
这是一家之说。
它是一个基本的分类。
但是呢。
也有。
观点认为。
一切视角。
都是全制视角。
没有所谓的限制。
啥意思呢？就是你内视角。
你以为你就是人物吗？
你就是人物吗？
你不是的。
你只是在伪装成一个人。
我们说。
故事永远是叙事者在讲述的。
是你在讲述的。
你是编剧啊，你是创作者。
你其实知道所有的事情。
你说你等于人物，你就真的等于人物了吗？
不可能完全等于人物。
你还是全职视角。
我们说你如果等于人物，假设这个人物在故事中。
就是你这个电影故事里面，你这个人物。
第一天。
嗯。
他爹被杀了。
第二天上路去报仇，第三天呢手刃了对手，把仇报了一共。
在故事里面经过了3天。
但是你呈现出故事。
是不是只用了2小时？
你为什么选择呈现这两小时？
他睡觉了那8小时，你咋没呈现？
对不对？
他睡觉前跟他媳妇儿还。
打了一炮，你咋没成现？
一共打了25分钟，但你只呈现了10秒，从热吻到脱衣服，然后哎结束了。
你咋不全城建呢？
你不说你等于人物吗？
人物经历了25分钟呀。
你咋只成现了10秒呢？
就说你不可能等于人物。
你在揉搓这个时间，你在时间这个维度上还是全知的。
因为你知道这边没用。
你知道这一段对剧情没有用，对后面剧情发展没有大用。
所以你给跳货了。
那谁允许你这么做呢？
你为什么要这么做呢？
不就是你还是天爷。
还是全芝麻。
所以有一种观点认为，没有所谓的全职限制。
所有的。
所有的视角。
都是全职视角。
只不过是我们有时候。
在某些故事。
里面需要伪装成自己不知道。
伪装成。
能理解吗？有点绕是吧？
就是在全职中。
本质上一切皆为全知。
但是在很多时候。
我们在全职中。
需要去。
伪装成。
限制。
很简单的道理，你如果不伪装的话，你给我讲一个故事，你是上帝。
你给我讲一个故事，讲2小时，中间有一段给我吓够呛。
有一点给我急得要命。
那我就问你上帝哎。
你全知呀，你告诉我后面怎么回事呗。
你为什么要掉我胃口呢？
你为什么要戏弄我呢？
你为什么要给我设置悬念呢？
对不对？
你能不能别装了，你明明什么都知道。
不就是这种情况吗？
就是说你如果。
牢牢坐在全职位置上上的话，是不是会会被人。
质疑。
所以说有一种观点认为，所有的视角本质上都是全职的，只不过我们在全职中。
寻找限制。
所以大家理解这种观点了啊。
就是本质上。
皆为全职，因为确实是这样，这故事是你写的，你作为叙事者，你当然是全职的，你知道后面咋发展。
但是为了。
达到故事的真实性也好，紧张性也好，流畅性也好，你需要把自己伪装成。
限制。
伪装成现实。
所以咱们。
记住一个。
后决。
也就是说你自己在创作故事的时候，你首先要锚定一个视角。
我们理解了这些理论之后，你自己在创作故事的时候。
首先你要锚定一个视角，比如说你锚定了你是全只视角。
你锚定了，你是全职视角。
你动悉一切吧。
你啥都知道吧。
你是上帝呀。
在全知视角的讲述里面，你自己要去追求限制。
你哪些藏着？
哪些不藏着，哪些故意视而不见。
这不就是限制吗？所以在全职视角里面，你自己要去刻意的。
寻找现实的尺度。
你如果觉得你这个故事。
适合比如说内视角或者外视角，也就是限制视角。
你毛定你是一个限制视角的讲述方式。
那么你需要在你的限制里面。
去找你的全职。
找你你的全职。
因为你。
并不是。
故事中的一个人物，或者并不是故事中的一个客观存在。
你还是需要想办法让观众获得。
全面的信息。
获得全面的信息。
这个比较难懂啊，我给大家举几个例子啊。
我们说。
刚才举过例子的摩登家庭。
摩登家庭我们说是一个外世家。
他很冷静，很客观的。
记录几家人的生活。
像个摄像机一样。
像一个冷血的观察者一样，整个片子像个纪录片一样。
我们说这种片子啊，它确实真实。
确实客观，却实冷静。
但是呢它缺乏温度。
他缺乏内心。
的东西。所以你去看摩登家庭，经常有一段戏演完之后，一家人坐在沙发上接受外视角的采访。
就外视角像个记者，像摄影机一样。
处在那儿，然后他开始解释，哎，我刚才。
骗了一下我老婆，其实我不是故意想骗他，因为有时候我真的很就是开始对着。
镜头。
开始叨叨。
这就是在限制中。
去想办法找点全职。
弥补一下。
你的。
问题。
我再给大家举个例子啊。
也是课上讲过的肖申克的救赎。
我们说肖申克的救赎是一个很典型的。
内视角。
内饰角非常典型。
非常典型的内视角，谁的视角？
red的视角，摩根弗利曼那个角色呀。
他第一次看到安y。
他是咋想的？安迪进到他们监狱，他觉得这个人是个软蛋。然后后来一步一步发现哇，安迪这个人不简。
他在讲述安迪的故事。
他在观察安迪的故事，就是说叙事者跟。
摩根弗里曼这个角色合二为一了。
这是典型的内视角。
当然他不是主角的那视角。
他是第二主角的内视角，或者说叫配角的内视角。摩根福利曼是配角，还是第二主角，咱们不去探讨，这是字面上的区别，没有意义。好吧，我们只说。
这是一个。
第二主角的内视角的电影。
他通过摩根弗里曼的。
视角。
讲述整个故事。
但是我们说了。
开场的那一段。
怎么算？
咋算？
开场那一段，安迪没进监狱之前，摩根弗利曼是。
从一开始就在监狱里的。
没进监狱之前，安迪那个案子，他的杀妻案是怎么发生的，怎么产生的误会，怎么审判，怎么怎么被。
冤枉。
这段。
red可没看到啊。
那这段算什么？
所以说这段实际上就是一段。
上级视角。
一段上帝时间。
他是用在片子开头，相当于一个前史。
你可以算他还没进正片，所以用了一段上帝视角，你也可以算他。
哎，就先用一段上帝视角，得把这个事儿讲明白，然后再进入。
第二主角的内视角。
弥补了他。
我们说内视角就是限制，你在现制中你。
知道的太少，有时候也不行啊。
你就在限实中寻找前值。
就硬加了一段上帝视角在最开头。
当然，肖申克救书里面还有一段。
我们说肖申克的救赎啊，肖申克这个监狱啊。
摩根福利曼这个角色。
到最后。
其实在那在最后出狱之前，所有的时间都在监狱里面。
都跟安迪在一起，所以他讲述安迪的故事是合情合理的。
这个视角没有毛病，但是其中有一段啊有一段。
那个谁那个养乌鸦的那个老头，你记得吧？有一个老头养乌鸦的岁数很大的，终身监禁，做了一辈子监狱。
然后呢，他出狱以后。
因为已经完全不适应外面的世界，他连车都没怎么见过，汽车都没怎么见过，已经完全不适应外面的环境。
自杀了。
这一段事情。
re的你咋知道？
你咋知道？
你是限制视角，你咋知道人家在监狱外面在超市打工，经历了什么？
你咋人知道人家怎么自杀的？
在这里，他很巧妙的运用了那个老头的来信。
也就是讲述这段戏的时候。
是re拿起了那个老头的来信，读那个老头的信，然后切到了那个老头的。
外面的戏份。
所以说这也是在限制中。
去尽力的寻找全职，去补足你的。
叙事问题。
你看这就是在实战应用中比较有趣的地方，对吧？权职中找限制，限制中找权。
当然了。
关于叙事视角比较有趣的片子有很多啊。
最典型的罗生门。
罗生门嘛。
罗生门也是一个内视角。
但是他换了好几次。
每一个角色。
都给你来一遍。
迹向内视角。
但是又客观冷静的。
像一个外事。
因为你也不知道。
究竟发生什？
究竟法。
同样在视角上大作文章的，还有一部电影。
非常有趣的。
少年派。
李安导演的。
安利李安导演啊。
少年派大家回去也可以回顾一下少年派是啥视调。
少年派。
讲述者。
是中年派。
中年派讲述。
他先讲述了他的童年吧童年。
然后又讲述了他的少年，而且中年派明显。
我们说在少年派里面既有一个讲述者，就是中年派，还有一个聆听者呢？
还有一个代表我们观众去聆听去质疑的那个家伙，那个记者。
大家去看一下那个视角切换也是非常有趣，因为中年派。
并不严格等。
少年派，我们说这个故事叫少年派的奇幻旅行，对不对？
这个故事叫少年派的奇幻旅行，对吧？
所以故事的人物。
其实是少年派。
但是讲述者其实是。
中年派。
等于。
中年派讲述少年派的故事。
确实是个内视角，但不严格。
因为这个中年派啊不说实话。
所以他是。
约等于。
也很有趣。
大家回去再看一遍好不好？这节课咱们就不留写作的作业了，留点看片的作业。
大家最起码回去把罗生门看了。
把肖申克的救赎砍了。
把少年派看了。
把那个摩登家庭副总统这种看了。
好吧。
去看一下这些大师作品。
在叙事视角上都能玩出什么花来。
这节课咱们只是在理论上概述嘛，我们就说概述，理论上电影的视角分三种。
上帝视角内视角外视角，它脱生于小说写作的所谓的第三人称和第一人称。
但是呢其实在很多理论里面又认为其实所有的视角都是全职视角。
本质上都是全制的，你在那装什么装？
你只是隐藏自己，伪装自己，你不愿让观众知道你是无所不能的上帝，你希望隐藏在他们。
身后或者旁边。
假装成一个现值视角。
所以我们说在实际的运用中，你写创作一个故事的时候，你如果锚定你的故事是全职视角，那么你在里面要去追求现知。
你如果锚定你是一个限制视角，你就要适当的开全只。
这就是我们在实战应用中。
所要注意的。
我希望同学们。
理解这些理论。
然后再去看一些那些。
经典的作品。
多体会，多学习。关于我们的这些知识啊。
我们不能只停留在纸面。
停留在理论。
我们需要知道视角都是些什么。
但是呢也不能完全被他ca死。
为啥？
因为啊。
这个知识这个东西啊。
技术这个东西啊，它其实是发展。
变化的它是流动的。
我们说你看过去啊都是全制视角，现在呢慢慢出现限制视角。
它一直在流动，一直在变化。为什么？我在课上以前说过，其实就是观众啊人民群众的欣赏水平一直在变。
所以呢你得不断的调整自己。
不断的调整。
你太全职了，你就要这个给他们点现制。你太限制了呢，你要给他们点全职。因为人民群众的需求在不断的变。
总体来说，过去肯定是全知多。
全击战绝对的主。
现在呢现汁。
慢慢多起来，但也并没有完全强调全职的风头啊，全职还是主流。
只不过限制越来越多了，我们一定要有这个发展的眼光，而且要知道它为什么发展。
你说为什么发展？
我们来看一下啊，你看啊小说也是。
就过去的文章文体全都是第三人称。现在为什么出现一些第一人称？我给大家讲一讲为什么。
第一。
过去讲述者站在站在上帝视角，我们说上帝视角是个俯视视角。
为什么过去创作者能站在服视视角呢？是因为在过去呀。
我们说古典。
那些年代。
创作者是以文化的人。
他识字啊，他还会写东西。
大部分受众。
大部分我们说讲述者是文化人，授术者。
听的的人呢。
他不识字啊。
所以你当然是站在一个很高的位置。
俯视着讲，哎，我给你们讲个故事啊，从前有个山山上是怎么回事？哎，这边我们讲的差不多了，你别别着急，山下有个村子，你就你确实是在像哄小孩一样。
在讲。
就是一个俯视视角。
电影初期也是电影刚出来的时候那。
这这个能创作电影的人，那也是人中龙凤呀，对不对？
所以他必然有一个俯视在。
但是随着。
现代社会。
的这个这个发展，咱们知道。
你你你你作为一个故事创作者，你的文化水准。
还真不一定有观众高，这是不是观众里面卧铺藏。
所以你看啊。
我们说为什么现在的。
好莱坞的电影。
发展。
最先出现的。
大量的内视角和外视角呢。我刚才说的那些内视角外视角基本上都是。
很现代的。
好莱坞影片为什么？
是因为他们的观众的知识水平。
比我们早更早崛起。
你已经很难。
不是讲故事吧。
你必须平视了。
甚至。
有时候平视都不平视了，你得躲出去了。
我只是给你展示哈，我不解读，你们自己看，我没文化，对吧？外视角了呀。
就是我不解读了，我我何德何能呢？
是不是？
这就是一种。
发展。
很正常啊，不是贬低水，抬高水就很正常。
因为。
家都识字儿，大家其实也都。
阅偏量也很大，大家都懂道理，大家也都念过书。
所以呢。
你要么就带入一个角色讲给我听，你要么呢就去你闪一边，你就给我拍出来，你把这些事情给我拍出来，我自己去分析，自己去解读。
所以呢这种限制视角。
会越来越多。
而且呢。
这是第一个原因，就是知识理解力。
文化层次。
原因。第二个原因呢也是观影习惯的原。
我们说。
现制视角呃或者说叫第一人称视角。
什么都是第一人场。
打游戏。
游戏都是第一人称啊。
明白这意思吗？
现在的年轻观众啊都是打这游戏长大的。
打着那种角色扮演类的游戏，或者你看像我打GTA。
荒野大镖客对吧？如龙就是我喜欢玩的游戏，都是第一人称。
大家习惯了这种。
视角习惯了这种叙事方式了。
这种限制的。
视角。
跟游戏很像，所以它也是时代的一种发展。
我们说。
老老人啊就老观众啊最早接触限制视角的时候，最早出现限制视角影片的时候，老观众看的时候会觉得头晕啊。
他了不用说理解不理解了，头晕都。
为什么他们没打过游戏呀？
他本不适应了。
讲一个很有趣的那个小小。
题外话啊。
就是其实有研究说。
汽车发明以后啊。
经常开车的人。
他的脑回路都变了。
就是从神经回路的，从。
气致性的角度都已经发生变化了。
为啥？因为你开车。
人啊以前走路的速度或者跑步的速度。
就是一个低速状态。
所以你处理信息的时候，哎，右边有个妞，哇，真漂亮，这裙子挺短的。哎，左边这个大汉好像是她老公别揍我，你处理信息就是很详细。
这是你处理信息的一种方式。但是人开上车以后，那车是什么速度啊？
对吧？
一脚油门下去。
100多卖啊。
你就不可能。
详细的处理信息了，你只能大概感觉哦，右边好像有条岔路哦，左边那个车差不多要并过来了。
前面呢有个红灯。
快要变绿了。你在。
大量的处理信息。
所以。
快速肤浅的处理信息。这么说吧，有点像我们刷抖音。
所以导致人脑处理信息的速度变快了。
但是呢变浅。
这不是呃不好啊，更更高效嘛更高效嘛。所以开车都能让大家改变脑回路啊，更不用说。
打游戏了。
更不用说这一代人都是玩电脑打游戏，对吧？
他们处理信息的。
方式视觉和大脑连接这个神经回路的方式已经跟过去的观众不一样了，所以他更喜欢。
第一视角。
更习惯第一视角。
这都很正常，这是发展，明白吧？就是说。
所有的技术都是随着时代在发展的。我们大家一定要有这个发展的观。
就理解他是怎么来的。
你才能。
知道。
他是怎么用的？
这节课呢咱们就讲一讲这个视角，叫概述一下，你理解一下都有哪些视角都是是不同的视角呢？适用哪些场景。你自己在创作故事的时候呢？
进行合理的选择和应用，好不好？
大家回去看一下参考片，再体会体会。
有什么问题咱们以后继续研究。
下课吧。
。
非常感谢曹老师这一年的辛苦教学。
在您的指导下，我们也会变得更加优秀。非常感谢你。呃，感谢查理老师教给我们这么多知识。然后我在查理老师这里也学了很多编剧的东西，然后恭喜查理老师呃三年抱两。然后呃多生贵子，就这样。嗨查理老师，谢谢你一年多的教诲。
多的陪伴，感谢相遇。
英俊客一周年生日快乐，感谢查理老师。
你的光头照照着我们。
感谢查理老师教书育人，祝老师身体健康。希望查理老师以后能越长越帅。
查理老师，这是您的学生在南太平洋给您发来的问候，预祝您在新的一年一帆风顺，满载而归。
感谢茶伊老师为我们打开了。
去殿堂的大门，同时呢也谢谢查理的编剧课陪伴我们度过了过去艰难的一年。hello,查理老师，感谢你过去一年多的。
在我最想学习编剧的时候，是你打开了我新世界的大门，让我真正的走上这条路，让我更坚定了自己的目标，要成为一名出色的职业编剧。感谢查理老师说，虽然做所有事情都像减肥一样有资格试进成。我减肥成功了，我也相信我可以在编剧入行成功。感谢查理老师的编剧课。
让我的创作系统化加快了我的创作进程。
老师你好，我是花里胡哨的咸鱼，一个刚入门的小白，老师的课帮我解决很多技术上的问题，也解决了我的一些困惑。希望老师的课以后越来越好，谢谢老师。
我是22班的学员，特别的惊喜，可以看到老师的编剧课，祝老师新的一年可以牛气冲天，大红大紫。非常感谢查叶老师跟柴叶老师学习的这一年，我已经写完了一部科幻的剧本，并且得到了几个大公司的回复。嗯，希望查理老师呢能够继续将这门优秀的课程办下去，我们的相处呢属于编剧学习。
咸于人格魅力，同时呢也祝愿查理老师的笑容永远这么阳光灿烂下去。
是22个人安达。
04年的时候有参与过老师监制的作品爱奇艺上上签。目前在北京的一家影视公司学习查理的微剧课，让我可以从另一个角度来了解整个行业。
非常感谢查理老师，祝查理老师的编具课一周年快乐，也祝查理老师永远开心，永远可爱。
茶艺老师好，我是R1级23班的小陈，很荣幸能在茫茫的网络人海中找到了查理老师的课程，让我又回到了大学的感觉，然后学习了很多编剧的技巧，编剧的知识，以及收获了很多一起热爱编剧事业的同学们。
林老师的编剧课，一周年快乐。
亲爱的查理老师您好，我是一个东北人，是本山传媒的一名演员，现在是一名新导演。
我呢是查理编剧课的受益者，特别的感恩您在您的课当中让我有信心，而且有方向，能够做好编剧这个行业，然后从事好导演这个行业，再次感恩您。老师，您的课东北人讲话杠杠的，没毛病。
22班女儿去家里老师等你快点想，快快穿头快。
9溜9爱是不知道。
就算你白。
四界。
谢这。
嗯。